tonight on our Southern border we're
going to take you there live as title 42
Now set to expire in less than three
short hours also Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg is at it yet again The Weeknd New
York City uh prosecutor is now buckling
to pressure and will now reportedly
charge that Marine named Daniel penny
with manslaughter after he restrained a
violent abusive mentally ill Criminal on
a New York City subway protecting fellow
passengers that were being threatened so
is this a case of self-defense if so is
self-defense now illegal right here in
New York City by the way the only normal
people in the city are right here in
this room
first
if you listen very very closely you can
almost hear I I am enjoying this way too
much you can almost hear the faint sound
the whimpering and the total complete
utter freakout and chaos and mess that
is over at CNN fake News headquarters
across town now in case you missed it
they hosted a town hall with former
president trump it did not go well for
fake news CNN now of course the
moderator in this case Caitlin Collins
she tried her best to make Trump look
bad and appease her I call it the blue
check mark media cult you know this this
group that only talks to themselves and
the mob and the media uh they hate any
and all things Donald Trump so instead
of focusing on important issues the
economy foreign policy Etc she spent
most of the Town Hall pelting Trump with
old gotcha questions questions he's
answered 100 times before mostly on
these old issues debated discussed death
take a look
he regrets about your actions on January
6th that jury found that you sexually
abused the writer Eugene Carroll and
defamed her you've denied this but what
do you say to voters who say it
disqualifies you from being president
well there was a tape deposition of you
from October in it you defended the
comments that you made on that excess
Hollywood tape about being able to grab
women how you want do you stand by those
comments some of your Republican Rivals
have criticized you for not fulfilling
the promises that you made on the
campaign Trail like finishing the border
wall so how do voters know that you
would get those done if you're
re-elected can you say if you want
Ukraine or Russia to win this war the
special counsel's investigation into
classified documents that were found at
Mar-A-Lago why did you take those
documents with you when you left the
White House I had every right to it by
the way she seems like a big fan of
Donald Trump all right here's where it
gets very interesting to CNN's fake news
is surprised Donald Trump he came
prepared and the audience well they
responded in a big way in his favor take
a look
why did it take you three hours to tell
them to go home I don't believe it did
oh let me pull it out
Manhattan jury found that you sexually
abused the writer Eugene Carroll and
defamed her you've denied this but what
do you say to voters who say it
disqualifies you from being president
well there aren't too many of them
because my poll numbers just came out
they went up okay
if elected president again what is the
first thing you would do to help bring
down the cost to make things more
affordable
drill baby drill
we had no inflation we had the lowest
Energy prices we've had in decades this
country was rocking and rolling and by
the way we had the most secure Border in
the history
but we have a very big mental health
problem in this country and again it's
not the gun that pulls the trigger it's
the person that pulls the trigger and we
have to protect our country is dying our
country is being destroyed by stupid
people by very stupid people you once
said that using the the using the debt
ceiling as a negotiating wedge just
could not happen you you said that when
you were in the philosophy so why is it
different now that you're out of office
because now I'm not president
all right in spite of the bias Trump was
great he got his points across he was
likeable extremely funny the crowd loved
him not the anchor in other words a
nightmare come to life for the producers
and contributors at fake news CNN they
invited Donald Trump to this town hall
and what a shock Donald Trump showed up
and they weren't ready for Donald Trump
now immediately following the debate
well fake news CNN they had their on-air
Powell uh panels spending hours and
hours despondent in shock and some look
close to tears even behind the scenes
there is an apparent Revolt among fake
news CNN's emotionally fragile employees
especially their left-wing woke anchors
uh by the way most of whom themselves
lie for three long years about Trump
Russia collusion that never happened and
as we speak and all our temper tantrum
is underway inside the company from top
to bottom bottom can you believe this a
leading presidential candidate former
president able to voice his opinions on
the air oh the horror of such a thing
now one highly emotional reporter I call
him a Humpty Dumpty wannabe some guy
named Oliver uh attacked his own network
posting this on his weird CNN blog that
nobody reads quote it's hard to see how
America was served by the spectacle of
lies that aired on CNN Wednesday evening
a spectacle of lies on fake news CNN
that sounds like an average night now
according to the Humpty Dumpty Junior uh
quote CNN and uh their new network boss
who might be fired over this let's see
what happens Chris Licht are facing a
fury of criticism both internally and
externally uh they didn't censor Donald
Trump for a whole hour and now CNN has
got to be punished needless to say it's
been a rough 24 hours for the media mob
and the Democratic party with at least
one comparison to January 6th uh take a
look
we're in a break now from the
presidential uh town hall with CNN
Caitlin Collins and whatever the they
thought they were going to get out of
this they instead have set a match to
democracy once again I saw a bad
stand-up comedian with a bunch of people
in his cult who love him and that is not
American as far as I'm concerned that is
not American and I think we needed a
Chiron This Is A Lie This Is A Lie This
Is A Lie this is a lie I think it was a
profoundly irresponsible decision I
don't think that it would I would be
doing my job if I did not say that he
declared war on the truth uh and I'm not
sure that he didn't win
wow how did the media mob get this crazy
and that triggered anyway for starters
they didn't really have contact with
people from different political
perspectives because they live in their
Ultra liberal areas their bubble in New
York City that the DC swamp uh they went
to ultra liberal schools they had
liberal professors their colleagues
their friends they live in a liberal
bubble they sing liberal Kumbaya songs
together they exist in one big far left
Echo chamber and so hearing from any
conservative is jarring to them
triggering to them especially if that
conservative is not always politically
correct and not easily intimidated or
silenced by their insults their
accusations and as we all know by now
Donald Trump is going to be Donald Trump
but here's what really makes those
so-called journalists so mad despite all
of their dire predictions Donald Trump
was a very successful president way way
way more competent than this guy that's
president today that doesn't know it's
Thursday night now that's why Biden is
now losing to Trump by a large amount in
a brand new poll as it turns out when
your livelihood and your retirement and
your safety and your security is at risk
when China's taking on America's role as
the world's leader with their alliances
with Russia Iran and others uh I guess
the guy with the Mean Tweets or comments
that might be politically incorrect
doesn't seem to matter too much so maybe
fake news CNN should really be thanking
Congressman Byron Donalds for bringing
them a dose of reality last night look
at this
first of all Town Halls are for the
voters not for the Press not for the
person who's the moderator Caitlyn spent
more time interjecting her own
viewpoints or her own look views on the
situation those were actually now are
you guys are you guys not going to
interject do I get a chance to speak
again
the town hall is for the president to
speak to the voters of New Hampshire not
for this back and forth media hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else